catherine alvarez a quitté cuba pour le
canada il ya près de cinq ans après un
emploi dans la restauration elle a été
embauchée comme commis à la peinture
chez rona elle est maintenant la gérante
du rayon c'était mon deuxième job au
canada depuis que je suis arrivé ici
j'ai trouvé qu'une belle ambiance de
travail pas seulement des mes employés
fassent aussi et aidait tout mes
directeurs des travailleurs comme elle
le centre de rénovation on a bien besoin
il compte déjà 240 employés mais on en
cherche d'autres il manque encore à 25 à
30 personnes en magasins dont une équipe
de nuit complète
tous les commerçants fait cherche des
candidats donc le marché de plus en plus
difficile que ce soit des caissiers des
commis ou des gestionnaires
lowe's la maison-mère de rona cherche à
recruter 1000 candidats en ce moment au
québec on s'assure d'avoir des salaires
compétitifs tout le monde ne débute pas
nécessairement au même salaire donc on
va prendre en considération le nombre
d'années d'expérience dans le domaine ou
pas dans le domaine mais au delà du
salaire on pense vraiment que la façon
de se démarquer c'est d'être un
employeur de choix
selon l'institut du québec 150 mille
postes sont vacants dans la province
après le secteur de la santé où plus de
30000 emplois sont à combler si dans le
commerce de gros et de détail que les
besoins sont les plus criants 20000
postes sont à pourvoir dans la
restauration il y en a onze mille c'est
particulier parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
demandes pour ces emplois là qui sont
rémunérés dont moins de 20 dollars de
l'arve
mais c'est en même temps des secteurs
qui ont été très affectés par la
pandémie pis là aussi il ya des chômeurs
pandémique le gouvernement legault
compte sur le bassin d'environ 300 mille
chômeurs pour mettre fin à la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre
mais selon me home si c'était possible
sans améliorer les programmes de
formation
tenez société aspire à se prendre les
chômeurs qui essayait de les replacer
comme l'allemagne plaide danemark sont
vraiment bons pour faire parce qu'ils
misent vraiment beaucoup sur la
formation formation en entreprise qui
quand ils soutiennent le revenu des gens
mais disent peut-être faire fourmis ses
stocks parce qu'on doit à migrer au
québec selon elle québec doit aussi
compter sur des immigrants pour combler
des postes dont le salaire est sous la
barre des 56 1000 $ par année
évoquée par le premier ministre le go
rien n'empêche de gravir les échelons
par la suite
c'est d'ailleurs ce que catherine compte
faire vraiment actif dans ma vie ici
olivier bascharage au canada mascouche